would a 10 year old choose to carry a baby?
I believe it would probably impact her life
and so therefore it would fall under any exception
and would not be an abortion.
wait, it would not be an abortion
if a 10 year old
with her parents made the decision not to have a baby.
that was the result of a rape
if a 10 year old became pregnant as a result of rape
and it was threatening her life
then that's not an abortion.
so it would not fall under any abortion restriction
in our nation.
Ms. Warbelow,
did you just hear some disinformation?
yes, I heard some very significant disinformation.
an abortion is a medical procedure
that individuals undergo
for a wide range of circumstances
including because they have been sexually assaulted.
it is still an abortion.
but there is no exception
for the life or the health of the mother
in the Ohio law.
that's why that 10 year old had to cross state lines
in order to receive an abortion.
a 10 year old rape victim was called a liar
by the ranking member of this committee
and I know that he did that
because he doesn't like
what that rape victim represents
which is that this law will bring us
government mandated pregnancies for 10 year olds
and they try and deflect that
because they don't want anyone in america to realize
that they don't just want to wage a war on women.
they're now expanding it to a war on little girls.